>> Greg: THE WHEELS ON THE BUS
ARE FALLING OFF IN KAMALA LAND.
INSTEAD OF GETTING SERIOUS ON
THE LARGING LEARNING DECLINE IN
DECADES FOR AMERICA'S STUDENTS,
SHE WAS TOUTING HER LOVE OF
YELLOW SCHOOL BUSES AND PUSHING
A $5 BILLION WHITE HOUSE
INITIATIVES FOR SCHOOLS TO GO
GREEN.
>> WHO DOESN'T LOVE A YELLOW
SCHOOL BUS?
RIGHT?
CAN YOU RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
LOVE A YELLOW SCHOOL BUS, RIGHT?
JUST -- THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
THE -- AND MOST OF US, MANY OF
US WENT TO SCHOOL ON THE YELLOW
SKULL BUS, RIGHT?
IT'S PART OF A NOSTALGIA AND
MEMORY OF THE EXCITEMENT AND JOY
OF GOING TO SCHOOL.
>> Greg: SHE REMINDS ME OF THE
RED WHEEL BARREL?
THIS IS A WEIRD CASE --
>> Jesse: I DO REMEMBER THAT
POEM, GREG.
>> Dana: .
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING YOU DO.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO LOOK AT
SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOBODY IS TELLING HER WHAT TO
DO.
NOBODY IS GIVING HER ADVICE.
LOOK, YOU'RE BEGINNING TO SOUND
LIKE A CRAZY SCHOOL TEACHER.
>> Jesse: AS A V.P., PENCE HAD
THE COVID TASK FORCE.
BIDEN HAD THE IRAQ WITHDRAWAL.
DICK CHENEY HAD A WAR.
KAMALA HARRIS' PORTFOLIO IS
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES AND SHE
LOVES IT.
YOU BUY THESE EXPENSIVE TOYS FOR
YOUR CHILDREN AND YOU GIVE THEM
A STICK.
THEY LOVE THE STICK.
HAVE AT IT, KAMALA.
DO YOUR THING.
BY THE WAY, A BIG INVESTIGATION
ON THE MONEY BEHIND THE ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSES, A LOT OF DIRTY
MONEY AND CHINA MONEY BEHIND
THIS.
>> Jeanine: THAT'S A SHOCK.
>> Greg: JUDGE, IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY HARMLESS.
IT'S A LOST OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE TALKING AND AN EDUCATION
CATASTROPHE.
THE PRIORITIES AGAIN ARE
REVERSED.
>> Jeanine: WE HAVE THE LARGEST
AVERAGE SCORE FOR READING
DECLINE SINCE 1990.
THE BIGGEST EVER DECLINE IN
MATHEMATICS IN HISTORY.
SHE'S WORRIED ABOUT ELECTRIC
BUSES.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
GOOD FOR HER.
SHE'S NOT -- SHE'S CLUELESS.
SHE'S WORRIED ABOUT ELECTRIC
BUSES.
SHE SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
CRIME.
THE THING THAT STUNS ME WHY
THESE ELECTRIC BUSES.
WHY?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I DID AS
D.A. WAS I DID A GRAND JURY
REPORT ON SCHOOL BUSES.
KIDS ARE NOT BUCKLED IN.
THERE'S NO SEAT BELTS ON SCHOOL
BUSES.
AND THE GENESIS OF THAT GRAND
JURY INVESTIGATION HAD TO DO
WITH A CHILD THAT WAS INJURED.
IT WAS  LIKE A PROJECTILE.
IT'S INTERESTING THE FEDS
REQUIRE US TO WEAR SEAT BELTS
BUT NOT KIDS ON THE BUSES.
PROTECTING THEM THAT WAY, THEY
WANT THE ENERGY PROPELLED SCHOOL
BUSES.
>> Greg: GERALDO, SHE DIDN'T
ACCUSE HIM OF NOT LETTING HIM
RIDE IN THE BUS.
>> Geraldo: SHE DID ONCE.
THEY DO TRIGGER A RESPONSE.
IF SHE BUNGLE HAD WITH YOU SPEAK
ABOUT, THE CATASTROPHIC LEARNING
SCORES IN MATH AND LANGUAGE AND
SO FORTH WITH THE -- USING THIS
AS A PEG TO DEAL WITH THAT
ISSUE, THAT IS -- HER
SPEECHWRITERS HAVE LOST A REAL
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
I ALSO THINK THAT CHILDREN
SITTING IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
DRIVEN BUSES AND THE EXHAUSTS
LEAKING AND THE -- SCHOOL BUSES
GET OLD AND THEY -- I THINK IT'S
A NICE IDEA.
I WENT ALL SCHOOL BUSES TO BE
ELECTRIC AND ALL GOVERNMENT
VEHICLES TO BE ELECTRIC.
>> Greg: I ALSO WANT A PET
UNICORN.
>> Geraldo: I WANT A PET UNICORN
ALSO.
>> Greg: WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT IF
GOVERNOR ABBOTT USED ELECTRIC
BUSES TO SEND MIGRANTS TO HER
HOUSE?
>> Dana: SEE IF THEY COMPLAIN
THEN.
HOW DARE YOU TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT.
I SAID ON THE LEARNING LOSS THAT
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD CALL A
CABINET MEETING AND ASK
EVERYBODY TO COME WITH TWO OR
THREE IDEAS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY CAME UP WITH?
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
KAMALA HARRIS AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES -- I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME
THE STAFF FOR NOT TELLING HER.
SHE SHOULD SAY OH, NO, I'M NOT
GOING THAT EVENT THAT SOUNDS
LIKE AN EVENT THAT PAY I DON'T
REMEMBER PETE SHOULD DO.
>> Greg: TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY.
>> Dana: EXACTLY.
MAKE HIM DO THE RIDICULOUS
EVENT.
>> Greg: HE SAID NO.
PROBABLY OFFERED IT TO HIM FIRST
AND SAID GIVE TO IT THAT LADY.
GIVE IT TO WHAT'S HER FACE.
>> Dana: YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT.
>> Greg: WE PROBABLY JUST BROKE
A STORY HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
MY SOURCES SAY THAT IT WAS
OFFERED TO BUTTIGIEG.
HE TURNED IT DOWN.
HE SAID GIVE IT TO THE LADY.
THAT'S